[Music]
republican representative marjorie
taylor green was in the news again this
week but this time it wasn't for
shouting at representative alexandria
ocasio-cortez through the mail slot of
her office store remember that we do
alexandria ocagio cortez i'm an american
citizen i pay your salary through the
taxes that you collect from me through
the irs you need to get rid of your
diaper and come out and be able to talk
to the american citizens instead of just
having to use a flap
very chill
now this time marjorie taylor green is
in hot water after a video emerged
showing her leaving the white house in
late december 2020. the video seems to
contradict her claims that she had
nothing to do with planning the january
6th attack on the capitol check it out
just finished with our meetings here at
the white house this afternoon we got
had a great planning session for our
january 6 objection we aren't going to
let this election be stolen by joe biden
and the democrats president trump won by
a landslide
well
that seems pretty cut and dry amber
amber ruffin god damn it what is it
marjorie taylor green is at the door
trick or treat smell my feet give me
something done to tweet marjorie taylor
green you get away from my door you
can't make me it's halloween the only
night of the year where i can legally
shout through mail slots
oh so you're in costume right now what
are you dressed up as a functioning
adult person
what are you dressed as a snowflake
marjorie you are being very scary well
mission accomplished now give me some
candy corn
candy corn who would ever ask for candy
corn someone who doesn't understand the
difference between good and bad now let
me in there amber
no way oh please please there's a bunch
of tiny socialists out here
how can you tell that they're socialists
cause they're asking for handouts those
are trick-or-treaters help help there's
a tiny iron man coming this way and i
think he wants universal health care
marjorie be honest did you help plan the
january 6th riots no comment
when the protesters stormed the capitol
did you high-five them no comment
can you answer any questions about the
insurrection
let me check with my lawyers
send
oh
well what did they say they said lose
this number okay
marjorie don't you have work to do
not really at this point shouting awful
things at people is pretty much my
full-time job so you have nowhere else
to be
that's right i guess i'll just have to
stay here forever
oh no sorry marjorie not happening tarek
i'm on it
melting what a worm
[Applause]
[Music]
you